want to get married but don't have a
significant other well you are in luck
because in Kyoto Japan a new company
called circa travel is offering solo
weddings yeah that's right we've got
some more info for you
Japanese luxurious wedding kimono or
dress you can have an on location
photoshoot and an entire experience tour
here's what it says on the website you
are single and you don't know if you
were able to get married and have a
wedding ceremony in the near future but
you would like to have some new pictures
of yourself in a wedding gown or in a
gorgeous bridal kimono now when you are
young and beautiful Steve I can see this
is for you or you even believe that you
don't really have to get engaged to be
able to wear a bridal outfit or you're
already married but didn't have a proper
ceremony with a beautiful dress and find
this fact to be quite regretful or you
did wear a dress but it was so long ago
that you would like to experience it
again or you were too busy with the
wedding preparations to enjoy yourself
fully during the special day and you're
looking for a second chance offering
yourself an opportunity to experience
the feeling of being a princess in the
beautiful and charming city of Kyoto
okay so just to be very clear you're not
actually marrying or so it's not
actually a solo wedding but you get to
experience it either again or UK it's
like a redo or a first time if you don't
have somebody yet you look good you're
young you don't even have a ceremony
yeah you just get dolled up and you get
all these pictures taken and you go
through the motions that a bride will go
through we're right before the wedding
with all the pictures all that and then
you can have a nice keepsake look how
beautiful I looked in this outfit and
here I am so I love it I think they're a
great idea yeah who do you think this
appeals to the most the girl that's a 22
and she's like I'm young and I look good
now and I want these pictures now but I
don't have a boyfriend or does it appeal
more to the one that like it all went
wrong you know it all went wrong but the
reality and this everything because it's
like it's a real modern take on wedding
it's like it's like wedding cosplay you
know and so but when you're actually
getting married the the bride is usually
fighting with her mother and it's
traditional marriage you know fighting
with their mother the flowers aren't
right
screaming at the caterer and so
authority they meeting charts everyone
getting charged yeah and and so you
can't really enjoy it I mean some people
do but you but it's difficult to and if
you know also the groom the groom does
nothing but ruin weddings mean the room
is you know it's just if the best
ideally the groom is just there doesn't
say much and then but often he's like
really hungover from the bachelor party
or his degenerate friends are they're
ruining it or whatever so the groom is a
real hindrance to a good marriage a good
wedding and so and a good match so I
think you know she's these are women who
are trying to isolate all the best
things about a wedding and cut out all
the fat and the unpleasant nice
I think you're overanalyzing I think is
just it well first of all cost $2,500 so
it's not super cheap right but it's also
way cheaper than an actual wedding I
just think it's it's for people who have
the money to have a fun experience I
think that's all it is so so whether
you've had a good wedding or bad wedding
whatever it is you want to get dolled up
and you know feel special and take all
these great pictures and there are
versions of this in the u.s. in a sense
that you can get glammed up yeah
and they take pictures of here right so
the glamour shots is a much scaled-down
version but it's similar yeah and I
think it I think it peels more to an
older woman who wants to maybe kind of
you know relive you know her past or
redo it in some way I think for or you
know maybe a young girl who wants to
just kind of see what it would feel like
but but Malcolm is right in the sense
that a real wedding even when everything
does does go right right it's still
stressful I mean because you have to
make sure that all your guests are happy
every time a good time and something
always gets screwed up I get always the
flowers and our right the food is wrong
peace is something something was wrong
so it's stressful and and you know at my
wedding
everything went pretty much according to
plan and I'm not a stressed out person I
don't really care about the same time I
was excited in order cuz nervous energy
it was it was so I could barely eat and
I remember everyone telling me you know
how good the food was at my wedding but
III don't know I don't recall at all
yeah and then like six months later my
parents threw me a
in a second reception in New Jersey for
people who can make out of California
and that one I was so relaxed I ate like
a pig I got drunk I danced more it was
great yeah and there's something
liberating about it not being the real
thing but kind of a real thing right so
people put so much pressure on
themselves for the weddings and
everything so I get it that this isn't a
real wedding but couldn't you see this
being the next step in what happens in
America so okay so gays are gonna get
married fine everything's gonna be fine
I know I know it freaks you people out
but it's gonna happen you know it's
ruining our marriage your personal
relationships but I really could see
this becoming something in America
people marrying themselves people that
say I don't want to get married I don't
believe in the institution of marriage I
don't I don't have a significant other
but I want the [ __ ] because so much of
its about the [ __ ] you want the cookware
and the knives and all that other stuff
well if you if you have a lot of friends
because your wife's using it to feed you
you just don't see it if you have a lot
of friends who got married and you spent
a lot of money on them and then you were
like hey I want some of it come back to
me what I think is really great about
this if it does go the direction you're
talking about is that another problem
that a lot of couples have traditionally
is sort of wedding night jitters you
know like what's gonna happen especially
if they have you know saved themselves
for marriage but if it's just you if
it's if it's just you by choice if it's
just you yeah you know I mean because
you're worried you're not gonna be
sexually compatible maybe with this
person but if it's just yourself you
already know you're gonna have a gear
that was a very handy tip